ちょっとですね用事があって今からタクシーに乗ってたくさん荷物持ってちょっと遠出
するんですけども共通の実験的にですねちょっとタクシーに乗るんですけどもその
タクシーの運転手さんを僕よぉ笑いの技術で笑わせられるかどうかというのはちょっと
実験してみたいと思います
理由は何な客だって自分では何やってるんだろうと思っちゃうルールは簡単ですよ
クレンジング
私を呼んで乗って遠くに行くんですけども行く途中で電車さんを笑わせられるかどうか
私分運転手さんもいろいろいるんですよすっごいらのすごい火災人もいれば
すごい論争にしゃべってくれる人もいるんで一概にねこれはうまくいくかどうかって
いうのは結構は牧師ない版ですけど運転士だしないっていうのもあるんですよ
うまく一番いいなぐらいの感じで実験的ねそれぞれのではないのテクニック読み熱愛
台北付けましょう
村外で綺麗ですねもうすぐ大衆くんですけどもまぁこれ俺のね笑のテクニックをし
ながらに見せてやるぜ
ぴょん
ん
ダーツ椅子でだ漫画稲蔵から
うーんだよねっ
rar
っていうことだそうなんですよなんかあらもうてなんかな
あのーなんかアイドル金谷そうねそれはすごく
youtube って知ってます数十年に何か動画を上げていって
こちらは投稿した得してますよ
ダブルと思って持っとくねーことですかよ
砂んどんなものいやーなんか本当に変なことをプリスクール
ん
ああ今のでよく見てるよ遊んとジェンダー水野碧
僕ですか
部屋に
ピッチングがシーンをセットしているの部屋で150キロのパッティングしたり
ああ
膵癌中で部屋の中です1マシーン
海外ん
二夜の中でそれはないうっ受け術っていう
本書ぴょっジャーマン見えないじゃ見えないですねほんと怖かったですよ
八つのやっぱご容赦入れました
あだったのでいや無理でした早すぎなぬ
あっはぁ
あっはいはいゾルじゃあねーや飯田れるじゃないですけど
なんで本当のようなんかどうぞビューアーでございますが
goo
ブーバーし
技やないとはまたねちょっとねーそうでカー大都会っ子色使いポイント気ねー
lo
尿漏れ
car
鷹揚な
nanonano
何もないんですよオール大丈夫もうちょいだをやや上にネッツアイドルアイライナー3
期目ですよ
維持を可能ダンスとか歌とかできないと言う
はい
昨日イントレですかーを
ブーブーいいすかぁ
うんいい子だ
御配慮して子どもだけしまいます
強い運転した笑わせるかどうかこう
企画だったんですよ
いい感じに終わっちゃいましたん
明日っていうありがとうございました
yeah あれぞいまさあどうしよう連れていってきまーす
あった
ana
me
ん